daniel mesguich bonsoir genre avant de
parler de la tempête on peut dire qu'on
vient de voir lund den berg et vous
venez de monter un le vol zag donc
l'autre oeuvre de bergues à montpellier
c'est ça comment pallier au corum de
montpellier
vous n'arrêtez pas j'arrête pas j'adore
l'opéra ou alors vous êtes metteur en
scène professeur directeur écrivain
acteur c'est pareil vous avez quel âge
j'ai 46 pas mal alors la tempête de
shakespeare à la comédie française s'est
donc c'est en alternance 1,6 en
alternance bien sûr avec tous les
spectacles bien sûr et c'est jusqu'à
quand c'est jusqu'à la fin de la saison
ou moins comme tous les spectacles de
val-d'or en alternance alors bon
l'histoire vous pouvez nous dire un mot
de l'histoire parce que je voulais
rencontrer beaucoup mieux que moi mais
c'est parce qu'ils le plus important non
enfin on peut en dire un petit mot je
sais bien mais en gros c'est un homme
prosperous qui a été déchue puisqu'il
était duc de milan ait lieu et que son
frère a fait alliance avec le roi de
naples pour le laisser dans un dans
l'océan comme ça perdu avec la pauvre
petite fille
il se trouve que entre temps une sur
cette île déserte où il a fini par
atterrir il ay là il est devenu un peu
magicien il fomente une tempête est un
bateau qui était qui comportait le roi
de nabeul précisément et son frère fait
naufrage tombe dans l'île déserte sans
doute pour se venger et puis finalement
ils leur pardonne et entre temps et ça
c'est la chose la plus importante
entre temps sa fille et le fils du roi
de naples se rencontrer ce marché c'est
le coup de foudre
voilà alors on a vu des mises en scène
récemment une giorgio strehler une qui a
beaucoup marqué les esprits en 1990 aux
bouffes du nord par peter brook sens en
effet sans décor peu aux antipodes
aux antipodes de de votre flux version à
vous alors les chances qu'on peut dire
ce qu'il veut apporter d'abord que vous
avez traduit
vous êtes donné une nouvelle traduction
de la pièce on vous a beaucoup reproché
un jeu pas entamé le débat qui aura lieu
après mais j'essaie quand même de
préparer le débat on a beaucoup reproché
les assonances et délibérations les jeux
de mots la chasse aux chaufferies souris
les poissons poisseux tous les qu'il est
et puis aussi les tournures un peu
médiéviste sita grand de thé voulait
alors traduire shakespeare avec des jeux
de mots qu'on a qualifié digne de
l'almanach vermot
vous répondez quoi je réponds que si ces
gens là avaient été critiques anglais
autant de shakespeare il aurait il
aurait descendu shakespeare où il aurait
en tout cas dit du mal de shakespeare
parce que ses jeux de mots sont dans
shakespeare c'est d'une grande culture
que de reprocher à une traduction de
faire des jeux de mots alors qu'ils ne
savent pas que ils disent non plus
nombreux encore et bien évidemment
shakespeare les criques en jeu de mots
bonne réponse alors leurs employés un
épilogue d'aragon fin peut prendre un
texte d'aragon plus tôt pour en faire
les pilotes de shakespeare ça vous
dérange pas ça non c'est un jeu le dit
d'ailleurs dans le programme c'est un
petit clin d'oeil
il se trouve que les pilotes de
shakespeare dit des choses très précises
morts il y à un texte magnifique de
louis aragon qui s'intitule d'ailleurs
épilogue donc un petit une petite
lentille gars comme ça et qui dit à peu
près les mêmes choses et c'est presque
une traduction c'est hallucinant comme
ça semble être une traduction pas
littéralement mot-à-mot bien sûr mais
presque et je me suis dit que c'était
mille fois plus bout de terminer comme
ça il faut dire aussi que les pilotes de
shakespeare dans la tempête et en
alexandrins enfin n'ai pas de raison
dans mes temps et en verre qui rime
celle à dire donc quelque chose qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec le reste de la
pièce
alors bon vous connaissez le mot on
parle de metz bichri pour dire tous vos
petits trucs se passait pas ça vous gêne
pas non pas c'est une marque de fabrique
un lui comme si vous aviez une marque
d'affection
les poupées qui traduisent le
dédoublement les jeux de miroirs et
cetera l'épée qui sont flamands une très
belle chose avait dit une fois le
théâtre doit vendre incandescent les
livres et dans une de vos pièces je me
souviens plus laquelle je lui avais un
livre qui s'il y avait un livre qui
brûle et je me suis un peu donc un
spectacle c'était ça doit être dans
titus andronicus mais j'étais déjà parce
que vous êtes un grand on va on va en
parler vous même un spécialisé monter
quelques shakespeare avant la tempête
alors bon on a tout entendu a c'est
kitsch et rococo c'est tarabiscoté ses
gonds goristes shakespeare devient
librettiste et
le librettiste de mesguich mais il ya
une chose quand même con une critique un
peu plus fondées c'est finalement trop
de machinerie nuit à la magie ce oui moi
je crois je crois qu'on peut pas dire ça
alors peut-être maintenant vous savez je
ne défendrai pas comment dire tout ce
qui peut être irrationnel de l'ordre de
5 me plaît ou ça me plait pardon l'a6
appelé par des gens simples et pas des
gens vers noël que voulez vous je dis je
vais pas inventer mon propre travail
ce que je peux dire simplement c'est que
là encore il s'agit un peu de culture
quand on reproche le fait qu'il y ait la
machinerie parce que c'est une féerie
ça a été fait quand elle d'ailleurs
shakespeare lui même à son époque
j'imagine je n'y allais pas mais des
documents sont là se servaient de tout
ce qu'il était possible de faire en
matière de théâtre d'une part d'autre
part si on a bien regardé le spectacle
mais certains critiques n'ont pas fait
puisqu'ils sont partis à l'entracte
c'est faute avouée n'est pas du tout à
moitié pardonnée enfin que c'est on
revient en 87 jours prochains à gilles
costaz et à tous les critiques de pas
être professionnel de mal faire leur
boulot et ne pas venir le jour où ils
disaient qu'ils ne veut pas ouvrir des
polémiques comme ça en tout cas mais
effectivement effectivement je trouve
que je n'ai pas très bien bref tout ça
pour dire que que lorsque lorsqu'on
regarde cette pièce on cette mise en
scène on s'apercevra je crois on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs les spectateurs le
dise que arrivé au moment où prosperous
dit et maintenant j'arrête tout je ne
veux plus d'effet tout cela est
finalement assez grossier tout il n'y a
plus d'effet dans la mise en scène c'est
à dire que c'est le théâtre dans tous
ses états enfin le verbe qui est en
train de travailler et c'est cette
remise en question de la machinerie la
machinerie n'est pas là pour illustrer
ou pour rendre spectaculaire de manière
naïve le théâtre encore que pourquoi pas
c'est un art du théâtre après tout
colère de la machinerie comme celui de
l'acteur comme celui des lumières comme
celui des costumes et il n'y a pas de
raison de deux de dénier l'existence là
où la validité de telle ou telle chose
deux thèmes tels ingrédients mais
d'autre part effectivement oui c'est une
remise en question de ce qu'est la
machinerie de ce qu'est la magie
machinerie au théâtre parce qu'il n'y a
pas de magie de magie vrai c'est
évidemment des effets de magie donc de
la machinerie bien sûr et la pièce le
thème même de la pièce 10 et finalement
si on ne le faisait pas mais pour dire
les filles et finalement si on va voir
cela il faut déjà pas tous les cas ça au
moins un avantage c'est que ça permet
d'apprécier le talent des artisans et
des techniciens de la comédie française
c'est vraiment un instrument remarquable
alors au delà au delà de ses critiques
ponctuelles sur la tempête là
critique qui était généralement à qui
vous est généralement adresser c'est
finalement dû d'utiliser l'argent public
pour prendre les textes classiques et
vous faire mousser à partir de ces
textes et disons que de vous servir vous
plus que les pièces que vous que vous
mettez en scène ce à quoi vous répondais
je suis peut-être un vieux tell me
disent qu'ils pensent que
l'interprétation est plus forte que la
création
oui c'est surtout de manière un peu
provocante que j'ai pu dire que ça mais
effectivement il n'ya que de
l'interprétation c'est ce que je voulais
dire que la création qu'est ce que c'est
que la création c'est déjà une façon
d'interpréter le livre les livres assez
le monde
enfin voilà il n'ya que de
l'interpellation il n'ya que de l'homme
qui est en train de mesurer ce qu'il
peut dire des choses qui le précédait
alors voilà donc vous êtes très
provocateur à 77 ans a déclaré je dois
rien à shakespeare au contraire
shakespeare me gloire espère j'imagine
que vous avez une explication pour ça
parce que vous êtes très oui mais je ne
faisais je ne faisais que leur cité a en
clin d'oeil des propos de vitez qui eux
même si tu es en clin d'oeil des propos
tout simplement de pascal le philosophe
pascal car pascal pendant la querelle
des anciens et des modernes disait moi
je suis pour qu'on respecte les plus
âgés dont je suis du côté des modernes
c'est à dire qu'en réalité les modernes
ont l'âge de l'histoire alors que le
pauvre aristote et d'un bébé il est à
l'aube de l'humanité il balbutie
seulement et il me doit le respect voilà
moi ce que je trouve très étonnant dans
votre vie c'est finalement suspect ce de
prédestination parce qu'au départ bon
vous êtes né en algérie est née à alger
votre famille était dans la boucherie je
crois non débouchés votre père était
boucher vous emmener au cinéma voir john
wayne et des péplums donc au départ et
vous avez commencé par le cinéma et
quand vous avez commencé le théâtre en
fait j'étais pratiquement jamais allés
au théâtre non le même pas pratiquement
pas du tout et c'est très étonnant
j'ai commencé à apprendre des scènes de
théâtre au conservatoire de marseille
alors je n'avais jamais mis les pieds
dans un terrain alors un peu tout autre
histoire apprécié de monter vers le nord
parce que malheureusement en 62
l'indépendance de quitter l'algérie nous
arriver à marseille de conservatoire
quand vous arrivez à paris c'est très
dur on est obligé c'est vrai se coucher
sous les ponts de faire la manche ou
c'est simplement pour pour la légende
non c'est un peu vrai mais enfin
évidemment ça fait un peu légendaire et
c'est pas tout à fait vrai c'est pas
aussi vrai que de besoin elles semblent
se dire mais effectivement oui je suis
arrivé je n'avais pas de sous mes
parents n'avaient pas d'argent donc je
suis arrivé à paris
un peu comme comme au xixème siècle ou
au début du siècle région monte à paris
on va faire l'artiste
et voilà effectivement j'ai dormi sous
le pont du carrousel plusieurs nuits de
suite faisait très très froid des gens
même l'été et puis je pense que
marseille alger et d'autre part je
faisais la manche où il ya une autre
chose dans votre légende je dirais que
je sais pas si c'est vrai mais c'est
qu'un jour au conservatoire la
bibliothécaire avait jeté à la poubelle
des revues comme tel qu à l étude s est
renseigné
je suis toujours prêt à céder des revues
comme et vous vous les avez ramassé dans
la poubelle quoi éviter le cas l'étude
est ce pire des trucs sérieux et c'est
un déclic pour vous c'est vrai cette
histoire et c'est tout à fait vrai oui
vous savez moi je viens d'une famille
qui avait un grand respect des livres
mon père par exemple quand un livre
tombées de la table c'est quoi un
parterre comme ça il ramassait il fait
un petit baiser
et puis leur posait sur le livre comme
si tout le livre était sacré lui même
les livres non religieux le fait qu'il y
ait un livre est une chose magnifique
divine voilà c'est un peu ça qui est ça
voulait dire et je voyais qu'on mettait
à la poubelle des revues que les élèves
du conservatoire de l'époque en tout cas
ne lisait pas l'inquiéter en double j'en
sais rien et donc d énormes cartons
comme ça je faisais tous ramenés chez
moi par an et j'y allais à pied parce
que j'avais pas d'argent pour faire le
pitre où un taxi donc j'allais chez moi
je retourne concerne quand je reprenais
les poubelles et j'ai eu une
bibliothèque entière de en 73 ou passer
le concours de comédie au conservatoire
de paris et l'a alors là ça vous rend
très très très fort dans le système
parce que vous avez la jalousie du
barbouillé de molière et vous arrivez
sur scène déguisé en docteur avec une
cervelle fraîche à la main 1 et c'était
horrible ailleurs parce qu'elle sentait
oui et j'avais envie de vomir pendant
mon mécène de complexe qu'il n'y paraît
évidemment
donc ça aussi c'est vrai et alors
cournot qui n'est pas n'importe qui et
michel cournot dit il faut voir en
qualité en 73 il y ce type est une bête
de théâtre complète il réinvente la mise
en scène et il va être un grand
directeur s'était senti dans 73 puis
après bon l'avenir lui a donné raison
puisque vous avez dirigé un certain
nombre de théâtre dont le théâtre du
miroir qui était un peu votre votre
compagnie alors que vous avez touché 70
mille francs du ministère de la culture
comme subvention oui les joueurs
photo non je n'ai pas joué au loto non
j'ai dit en manière de provocation à
l'époque où ce n'est pas assez pour le
travail que nous faisons parce que vous
savez à cette époque là on parlait
toujours de alors de vitesse de bourdais
de lavaudant de cheyrou et lra de
vincent et de moi hein vous mettez les
jeunes mettent en scène les nouveaux qui
arrivent à comme ça sur le devant de la
scène d'une certaine manière
or tous plus ou moins avait des théâtres
des maisons ou des subventions voir des
troupes et moi non et j'avais donc fait
une demande en disant écoutez il faut
absolument que que j'existe vraiment que
je puisse vous préparez des spectacles
en avançant fin programmée des choses à
voir une action à moyen ou long terme et
on avait donné sept 7 70 minutes puis de
les jouer au loto vous avez investi dans
une brochure la voilà c'est ce que j'ai
dit j'ai réécouté de nos données mois 70
millions si vous n'avez que ça va donner
mais alors un papier signé il irait j'ai
le droit de jouer au loto mais comme ça
j'aurai une chance peut-être le fait de
l'avoir une véritable réponse donc après
ont malheureusement on n'a pas le temps
de tout passer en revue il ya eu le
théâtre gérard philipe à à saint-denis
et puis après lille donc le centre
dramatique national de rebaptiser la
métaphore entre guillemets et vous êtes
quand même toujours professeur au
conservatoire de paris vous quitté l'île
en juin est ce que vous êtes candidat à
la succession de nickel à la comédie
française
on va écouter cette c'est une affaire
qui fait long feu là aussi j'avais andry
d'ailleurs une émission à la radio je
sais plus même ça ou c'est normal qu'on
pense à vous c'est plutôt flatteur non
non bien sûr
écoutez moi ce que j'ai ce que j'avais
dit à un moment comme ça c'est je me
sens tout à fait apte à diriger un grand
théâtre à paris pourquoi pas la comédie
française brutes mais en réalité je le
dis solennellement jean pierre miquel je
crois vraiment été inquiété en est un
très grand tennis interne de mes
différents et je ne suis pas candidat
contre jean pierre miquel alors je le
serai contre x ou y quelqu'un d'autre on
pas mais sûrement pas contre jean pierre
michael hill pour terminer il ya deux
phrases en fait de deux citations une
vo2 bausch était arrêté à nouveau un de
vos maîtres et il disait l'auriez vu la
photo et la photo qui bouge après la
photo qui bouge et qui parler vous allez
voir bientôt on va le cinéma va arriver
au théâtre c'est assez joli
oui c'est à dire que les projets
techniques sont ce qu'ils sont mais ça
n'empêche pas que le comble du comble du
comble voilà je te ra cette chose toute
simple qui est un texte en acteurs
impliqués la magie c'est ça le dur un
ami parce qu'on parlait on parle du
théâtre justement il se disait coûte le
théâtre comment t'expliquer parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui dit allez pas
souvent jc comme l'imaginent nouvelle a3
la 3d mais imagine la 3d en mieux c'est
le théâtre et j'ai été très frappée de
voir la phrase de
la dernière phrase une belle citation
est ce que ça vous illustre assez bien
c'est parce que le théâtre est toujours
sur le point de mourir qu'il vit encore
et c'est vrai qu'on a toujours
l'impression que cet art on en parle
toujours comme d'une cause humanitaire
est en fait c'est très vivant enfin moi
depuis que fait cette émission j'ai
tendance à y retourner pas mal et ça ça
bouge bien non je crois que le théâtre
est une chose bien vivant bien sûr cela
dit il n'est pas éternel
2 après tout il a été plus ou moins
ventée autant d'eschyle grosso modo et
il ne rien ne dit que il durera tout le
temps rien ne dit non plus que regarder
par exemple la planète vous verrez que
qu'il ya qu'en occident en europe en
amérique et puis bien entendu en afrique
colonisé si j'ose dire même encore
maintenant
et puis et puis dans quelques endroits
de d'asie jeune papa de la russie mais
le même plus loin qu'il ya du théâtre le
reste de la planète ne connaît pas le
théâtre est croissante et à y aller px
en théâtre absolument donc savait pas ce
n'est pas obligatoire la littératie
c'est pas parce que nous on en profite
que tout le monde en profitera t
exactement donc dont il faut se méfier
quand même c'est une chose fragile et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que les
critiques fasse attention à ce qu'il dit
je reçois maintenant christine au crâne
pour la parution chez plon des grands
patrons et pour la sortie en kiosques de
l'européen un magazine et de l'union du
monde et de 10 européennes déjà
présentatrice de la mensuelle france
europe express sur france 3 aujourd'hui
directrice de l'aide de l'europe en
christine nous prouve que l'europe elle
ne s'en fait pas tout un monde
bonsoir vous avez bien alors donc que
vous faites effectivement déjà sur
france 3 le fameux dimanche soir qui a
été immortalisée par les guignols avec
vos amis ah oui là je dois dire
ensuite bon bah évidemment
france europe express mensuels 1 20h35
les émissions de société du mercredi sur
france 3 est longue est un peu
effectivement maintenant madame madame
europe qu'avec cette émission et vous en
profiter pour lancer l'européen donc je
vais le montrer à la caméra comme on
fait la télé voilà européen
alors c'est un journal au départ celui
des de maxwell c'est maxwell qui voulait
faire un cheval pour nous il ya eu un
journal en langue anglaise qu'il faut
dira pas beaucoup marché meilleure que
qu en angleterre et qui a été rachetée à
la borne maxwell sondages c'est spécial
et qui a été racheté par une famille
s'appelle barclays n'a rien à voir avec
la bni arrêté et qui s'est prise de
passion pour la presse tout en faisant
son argent dans d'autres activités qui a
racheté en grande bretagne des journaux
notamment le score semaine qui est le
plus vieux journal britannique journal
écossais de très bonne qualité et duncan
barclays deuxième génération barclays a
eu l'idée qu' il était temps de créer en
europe continentale comme disent les
anglais à commencer par la france
un hebdo en français pour des français
en partenariat
en l'occurrence avec le journal le monde
et donc nous avons forcément large et
c'est la première fois que le monde
oui d'abord la première diversification
dublin il faut quand même le souligner
est déjà tout le monde va très bien oui
un journal font confiance aussi alors le
monde évidemment ça vous donne accès à
tous leurs correspondants en europe
donc c'est un hebdomadaire c'est
mercredi ça vaut 15 francs et vous avez
80 mille exemplaires veut y arriver
quand même c'est pas une ambition
démesurée et si on fait plus on sera
content oui le mayroy que vous venez de
montrer très très bien parti nathan du
numéro 2 on est ravis pour vous alors
donc effectivement vous dites moi pas
faire le mal au dos le salaire des
cadres envers l'europe c'est à dire en
fait rien de ce qui nous concerne les
franco français qu'aux films européens
ont fait nous et les autres c'est vrai
que tous les problèmes qui nous
préoccupent nous que ce soit la
délinquance les enfants le bien-être le
chômage enfin tout ce qui peut traverser
le champ de nos préoccupations
eh bien on retrouve exactement les mêmes
préoccupations chez des gens qui nous
ressemblent et qui sont acer france et
ce qui se passe
et puis on va voir aussi quelles sont
leurs solutions au lieu d'inciter
concrètes capter des choses à prendre
pour nous et puis on voit bien surtout
avec les jeunes générations que j'en
sais pour le temps qu'ils diouf se dire
qu'on est enfermé dans l'hexagone et
voilà on est tous nomades alors je viens
aujourd'hui à l'aide par raconter tout
le sommaire du journal parce que les
gens n'ont qu'à l'acheter de toute façon
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il y
à un sondage on s'aperçoit que les trois
valeurs qu'on retrouve dans tous les
pays d'europe dans cet ordre là c'est
justice travaille et libertés il ya un
truc moi qui m'a beaucoup plu sur les
grands monuments ou qu'on fait à en
cette fin de siècle notamment lange qui
en angleterre ça très bien les
obsessions millénariste voilà oui c'est
le monument 1 c'est très bien ça et puis
alors effectivement il ya l'idée de le
faire ailleurs c'est en italie en
espagne enfin j'imagine que derrière la
famille barclays aura à coeur et vous
aussi de le faire ailleurs
alors bon malgré tout ce qu'on peut dire
quand même c'est que ça donne de
l'europe une image plus sympathique que
d'habitude mais c'est pas encore quand
même extrêmement grisant quand même si
elle est toujours une approche comme un
peu aride non monsieur l'europe pour les
gens c'est ce que celle europe 1 c'est
triste c'est qu'on sent pas de l'europe
ont pas européen et qui est européen
c'est vous et à partir de là qu'est ce
qui nous intéresse c'est nous d'abord et
donc puisqu'on voit à quel point sur
tous ces jours ci le discours politique
patine à quel point on trouve pas
vraiment les réponses on ne trouve pas
non plus toujours les recettes on tourne
un peu en rond entre toutes sortes de
faux experts et puis une presse qui
raconte un peu aussi toujours la même
chose est toujours un peu gnan c'est
clair jour là là ça va pas mais on est
bien sûr la sur la une
il ya un désir de refaire et c'est vrai
que l'idée c'est exactement ça ouvrant
les fenêtres un peu de commentaires et
et puis essayant de comprendre aussi
comment les onc nous vois c'est ça c'est
une vraie obsession pour les français au
contraire avant vous aimerez 1 surpris à
bombay temps alors les grands patrons
alors ça c'est autre chose c'est un film
vous avez fait un vieux livre parle en
effet que jean-pierre ceriani qui
travaillent avec vous on y travaille on
il a fait un petit un édito dans
l'europe est un fait partie de l'équipe
alors bon c'est tous les grands patrons
français leveaux d'un casting un casting
d'enfer on va pas tous les citer mais
enfin beffa lagardère pineau ernest
antoine seillière qui lui aussi est
immortalisée par les guignols david de
rothschild riboud donc ses patrons
voulez vous leur demandez comment il
voit la france dans vingt ans comme
enjeu la même c'est comme l'européen moi
je trouve qu'on vit dans un pays qui est
asphyxié toujours par un discours qui se
ressemblent et c'est un discours
monopolisé il faut bien le dire par la
classe politique qu'elle soit de gauche
ou de droite et on se rend bien compte
que ces gens là quels que soient leur
très grand talent et bien en fait il
nous conte de quoi il cause d'abord de
même on n'entend jamais en france les
patrons
les patrons sont dans le réel ils ont en
général entre ce que l'on a choisi ils
sont dans des activités très différentes
bourguignon pour le club med lescure
pour canal enfin ce sont des gens qui ne
sont pas touche dans l'industrie lourde
et qui ont une vision du monde a une
vision de la france et une vision de
notre société qui est autrement
concrètes et qui est autrement tonique
pourquoi parce que n'ont pas de complexe
et gens là ils se vouent mesuré en
général ils sont assez réussis ce qui
marche moi et puis en général ils sont
quand même assez un petit comme on
dirige y sont assez pudique qui sont
assez frileuses parce qu'ils veulent pas
qu'on leur met des tic est hélas comme
bouton par louis le nouveau patron de la
société générale qui est pourtant
approche du juppé dont il a été le
directeur de cabinet quand il dit tous
les hommes politiques mentent
c'est rare d'avoir un grand pat en
france vous savez les faire parler c'est
clair alors vous en faites l'européen
c'est un peu un retour à la case départ
parce que votre père était directeur de
cabinet de charles henri spaak est un
grand européen devant l'éternel et en
fait vous vous étiez vous avez commencé
au bureau d'information de la série
c'était mon premier job européen
un retour à la case départ ce qui nous a
beaucoup aidés aussi dans la vie c'est
d'avoir travaillé pour nbc et cbs parce
que les télévisions a évidemment hâte
d'évoluer aux etats unis quand en france
et vous aviez cette image de superwoman
dès le départ mais si vous savez bien
parce que les d'abord c'est une femme
jolie et puis ensuite le fait de votre
avis pour ses chaînes américaines ça
vous donne une aura une forme et
d'information sur lui après beaucoup de
choses à commencer par l'humilité parce
que ce soit des gens qui travaillent
c'est une histoire extraordinaire mon
ancien patron mike wallace qui à 79 ans
il a grillé absolument tout le monde à
bagdad lors de la dernière crise avec
l'irak il a eu sept ce scoop absolument
extraordinaire où il a accompagné le
secrétaire-général des nations unies
partout il y avait une petite caméra
avec lui alors il a demandé avant d'en
donner à un dîner officiel à son voisin
grange irakien moustache évidemment j'ai
pas très bien me servir de cette caméra
voulez pas vous en servir pour moi je
voudrais souvenir devant tout le monde
est d'accord oui bien sûr et il s'est
fait filmer en train la musette
ça ce sont des leçons de alors vous
acharnement professionnel je vous dresse
un peu je suis désolé parce que
malheureusement le temps nous est compté
vous avez quand même une carrière qui a
été pleine de rebondissements en fait et
vous êtes toujours là ce qui prouve que
vous avez vraiment la santé c'est
tarantino qui disait tout à l'heure
c'est on n'a pas la peur désiré mais
vous avez vous avez vraiment le désir
alors il eu bon là on va pas revenir sur
la sphère aux veilles dames enfin c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque j'ai quand même été
mise en cause par le figaro doors et
gagnez votre procès contre max clope
devient interviewé hoveyda qui était
quoi premier ministre du shah et ans
dans sa prison en pleine révolution et
l'interview avait été gardée par la
direction de france 3 à l'époque c'est
vendredi soir et étaient passés la
veille du jour où il a été fusillé
ça vous avez été reproché par le figaro
qui vous appelez l'assistante du
bourreau et ça a été quand même un coup
de fil ont perdu leur procès ensuite
j'ai été la première femme à présenter
le 20h
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas me répondre
mais tant pis vous pensez quoi de claire
chazal et béatrice schönberg son
charmant mais voilà j'étais surtout des
médias
vous avez dit quand même je n'aime pas à
guichet vous avez répondu par avance
ensuite vous avez participé à la
privatisation de tf1 d'abord avec
lagardère ensuite à garder la semaine a
perdu
vous êtes parti chez bouygues quand même
sens avec quelques autres
bonjour moi je suis parti assez vite oui
c'est vrai vous aviez des déclarations
au monde qui vous avait valu quand même
votre addiction différents points gt gt
l'audimat est à l'aise l'audimat dans
les ascenseurs ce n'est pas votre truc
c'est pas sur moi je suis tout à fait
pour l'audimat
on a tous besoin de mesurer aux faveurs
du public c'est pas ça non me disant
qu'ils aient à l'époque surtout un état
d'esprit qui n'était pas le mien
cela dit vous aviez déclaré quand même
le 16 novembre 87 donc c'était avant que
ça aille mal la privatisation de tf1 est
on ne peut plus positives
ça c'est vrai moi je continue de penser
je regrette ce qui s'est passé avec
hausse théorique
je pense que si lagardère elle avait eu
la culture de cette grande chaîne
privatiser aurait été différente pour
des raisons de tradition d'émotion il ya
des journaux bien sûr et des travaux
publics à la télé sans quelques frappes
sans casser des briques vous pensez que
le dur on peut passer de hachette
vous pouvez maintenant je ne sais pas
d'histoires très essentielle c'est
important vous pensez que le mieux
disant culturel de léotard parce que lui
aussi ses 86 normes attend les maisons
vous n'êtes pas un homme politique mais
il faut que les hommes politiques on le
rappelle ce qu'ils ont dit parce que
sinon c'est pas du jeu les pauvres si si
alors après les antennes de bon là il ya
eu encore de nouveau un choc terrible
pour vous parce que vous aviez un
salaire qui aujourd'hui semble
absolument naturel mais qui à l'époque
avait choqué c'était sans fin qui avait
surtout comment dire permis à quelques
agitateurs de démarrer une grève
et là vous vous avez vraiment un vrai
problème c'est parti à l'hosto pendant
pendant pendant un mois avec une double
pneumonie donc ça vous a très bien
informé si je me souviens fort mais
c'est normal non et vous dites je suis
entré en solitude c'est à dire qu'à ce
moment là vous avez vraiment c'est là
vous avez compris que finalement tout ça
à la gloriole qu'on peut tirer de la
télévision c'est pas grand chose et vous
êtes et j'avais la chance je crois de
comprendre ça à ses tours justement
parce que j'avais été formé au contact
de grands monstres hantent le 10 mai de
l'athénée des gens qui sont encore
toujours d'immenses stars ne serait-ce
que voilà ce dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
donc j'ai jamais été très dur tout cela
mais c'est vrai que il ya des moments
entre le personnage qu'on vous fabriquer
les coups que vous pouvez recevoir il ya
évidemment c'est aussi ce que l'on peut
faire ou que l'on peut donner
mais c'est vrai de but non mais je veux
dire par là que moi ma passion c'est le
journalise
mais c'est bien pour ça que je lance ce
nouveau journal et ce nouvel hebdo qui
est évidemment à paris si je voulais
gérer une image de petite star parce que
la télé ne fait jamais que fabriquer de
petites stars en sont pour celle là j'ai
l'âge de le croire aussi
voilà mon frère et vous comment gérez
vous aussi vous avez pris des risques
j'ai pris aussi à des trucs qui marchent
pas mais qu'est ce qu'on aime on aime
faire nous sommes des artisans ont même
fabriqué des choses qu en dites moi bon
il ya un truc quand même moi que j'ai
jamais trouvé très clair chez vous parce
qu'à part ça faisait plus d'une quart et
c'est d'aller interviewer en vous l'a
déjà dit je sais bien mais enfin vous
avez ta vie le président la république
avec anne sinclair et de deux épouses de
ministres
nani oui ça vous choque pas alors c'est
l'école américaine vous qui parlez
toujours de l'école américaine mais
c'est pas en amérique on n'a jamais vu
de femme de ministre à l'école
américaine c'est aussi de considérer que
les femmes sont au moins les égales des
hommes et donc qu'elles n'ont pas non
plus nécessairement à dépendre de la
carrière ont du parcours de leur jules
et donc moi je considère quelles que
soient les immenses mérites du bien que
blanc je suis champagny 55
ça ne dépend pas de ce qu'il peut faire
lui je veux dire moi la manière dont je
verse mes activités
quand même des retraites 7 sur 7 parce
que dominique strauss kahn est de
nouveau faim ministre vous vous quittez
pas votre émission pour les mêmes
raisons j'imagine non enfin je n'ai pas
non plus comment dire nécessairement les
mêmes raisonnements et peut-être pas non
plus les mêmes vraie raison parce qu'il
ya aussi ce qu'on dit et elle est
revenue à 5 heures donc oui il est
revenu plus tard elle a jamais voulu
inviter par mois le jeu mais voulu
inviter le pen exhale est invité le pen
non pas 7 sur 7 mais dans une autre
émission qu'elle faisait à l'époque si
ma mémoire est bonne avec colombani et
les questions à domicile
elle est même allée chez le pen à
latrinité surzur
cela dit moi je ne lui jette absolument
pas la pierre elle a été insulté
nommément personnellement de façon
immonde est inadmissible par le pen et
c'est à partir de ce moment là et ça
elle a mille fois raison moi je ne suis
pas dans cette
dans cette hypothèse heures je fais avec
gilles leclair une émission politique
tous les dimanches soirs et c'est vrai
que nous avons invité le pen comme
gollnisch etc et maigret franchi
quelques mois d'avoir invité le peuple
non qu'il reproche qui a quoi qu'il dise
qu'il le fasse ce qu'il veut
je sais pas à nous journalistes de
décréter qui est en dehors du champ de
notre démocratie politique
le jour où le comble le parlement réuni
en congrès à versailles décrétera le
front national hors la loi ce sera autre
chose
pour le moment nous avons nous sur l'a3
une la charge d'une émission politique
et doit recevons les hommes politiques
ou des responsables politiques très bien
et mal mais voilà merci
alors je rappelle donc l'européen
maintenant tout le monde a bien compris
15 francs tous les mercredis et puis ce
livre qui est paru chez plon qui est
très intéressant avec jean-pierre cela
dit les grands patrons comment il voit
notre avenir
merci bonsoir eric emmanuel schmitt si
vos parents qui l'ont appelé eric
emmanuel oui oui suggère quoi maintenant
c'est bizarre non puisque c'est à dire
conjuguant mon père est blond aux yeux
bleus
oui et quand je suis né
gt gt bras j'avais pas les yeux bleus
ils sont dit eric schmidt ça fait
vraiment non nordique
alors ils ont voulu à 12 sur ça avec
emmanuel donc c'est un prénom qu'on a
changé quand je suis arrivé c'est bien
ouais alors rien vous prédisposé à
devenir l'auteur que vous êtes parce
qu'en fait votre mère était le
championnat de course à pied et votre
père était boxeur c'est ça vous a péri
t1 du look de boxeur le nez aussi à
l'honneur c'est bon ça c'est ferry on
peut en hérite et vous avez découvert
l'écriture comment parce que c'est quand
même là aussi vous étiez pas c'est à
dire que pour se débarrasser de moi
quand j'avais 8 ans je crois un jour mes
parents m'ont posé au théâtre et j'ai vu
c'est un autre bergerac joué par jean
marais c'était un tiers des célestins à
lyon
ouais et j'étais bouleversée quand je
suis sorti j'ai dit à mes parents je
veux être le monsieur qui a fait pleurer
tout le monde et m'ont dit jean marais
j'ai dit non et de mon ressort
voilà et à partir de là à l'abri voulait
être un geôlier de claudel et puis à une
copine qui vous a dit accepte à
facilités voilà et tu seras sacha guitry
ce qui est déjà pas mal
ce qui serait pas mal puisqu'il serait
ce qui serait alors vous n'êtes pas un
surdoué
vous êtes super gentil super modeste
mais enfin quand on regarde votre
parcours sans parler de vos succès au
théâtre enfin normale sup agrégé de
philo à 23 ans docteur troisième chic
thèse sur diderot et la métaphysique
maître de conférences en philosophie
vous êtes l'âme à 1 bat pas la grosse
tête mais tête d'oeuf un peu quand même
c'est pas si c'est à dire à défaut oui
mais vous savez les études quand c'est
facile
c'est aisé d'aller jusqu'au bout et ce
qui compte c'est en sortir moi je dis
toujours rentrée normale sup c'est rien
c'est en sortir c'est à dire oublier
tout ça est arrivé à créer
oui quelque chose d'original la rive est
soi-même malgré tout c'est parce qu'on
font une instruction c'est une somme
d'influencé
vous savez comme disait cocteau à force
d'être un caméléon pour y ont fini par
mourir d'étouffement sur une couverture
écossais donc moi j'ai longtemps eu peur
d'être comme ça trop trop souple trop
doué et j'ai pris j'ai pris le temps de
me chercher
apparemment vous êtes trouvait donc vous
avez on va parler après bien entendu du
visiteur puisque c'est le sujet qui vous
amène mais on peut dire pour les pour
ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient pas que
vous êtes l'auteur de variations
énigmatiques qui a été jouée par de
longs et uster à marignier aussi du
libertin avec bernard giraudeau
il ya eu un vide dans votre carrière ce
golden jo a un sacré bijoux et golden
shoe bomber il était très bien ces
termes à renucci way et qui jouait avec
francine bergé et d'autres acteurs mais
la marche est enfin je ne sais pas avant
a beau s'annoncer pas non je ne sais pas
et puis en plus c'est la seule de mes
pièces qui n'est pas jouer à l'étranger
je me dis que ça vient peut-être de la
pièce ouais bah oui là comme toutes les
autres marchent très bien à l'étranger
le visiteur a été créé en 93 ce a obtenu
trois molière s'est jouée aujourd'hui
dans le coin 15 pays n'ont plus que ça
maintenant j'avoue que je fais plus le
compte ou au début il ya quelques années
quand je m'endormais le soir je me dis
alors aujourd'hui je suis jouer à buenos
aires et à hambourg et c'est que dans
black le décalage horaire vous étiez
joué juhan et ont poussé sa maintenance
j'y pense plus et puis en fait pour moi
les choses se passent ma vraie vie est
ici quoi c'est à dire quand j'ai une
pièce qui commence comme en ce moment là
ni je ne suis que là vous n'êtes pas
trop lourd avec le real à vous passer un
petit peu comme ça vous passez dire
bonjour aux acteurs mais vous laisser le
réalisateur faire site c'est à dire que
moi je ne suis pas capable de faire plus
qu écrire c'est à dire que je n'aurais
jamais le courage de mettre en scène mes
pièces parce que
je doute trop de ce que je surfe ouais
je fais et si un acteur tout simplement
parce qu'il s'est mal levée lorsque son
costume lui plaît pas me disait la
réplique est mauvaise moi je le croirai
alors que le metteur en scène sera
décryptée et se rendent compte qu'ils
parlent d'autre chose
donc je laisse ça les gens ils éliront
frankiz de ce texte a été publié
bien sûr il est chez actes sud avant
très bien et je peux même dire que c'est
le texte de théâtre qui s'est plus vendu
depuis ces vingt dernières années
je dirais pas encore une fois mais ça
mérite alors l'idée bon l'idée il ya on
est en effet frey de juste après
l'anschluss donc à 38 ans 38 il ya un
membre de la gestapo qui vient qui
débarque qui fini par emmener la fille
anna la fille de freud et puis débarque
un personnage a raconté noir ben oui
c'est à dire c'est une nuit ou fruit
d'un mal c'est une nuit où les
malheureux puisque on lui remet la
gestapo emmène sa fille et et cette nuit
là est ce que est ce qu'il a un songe
est ce qu'il fait un rêve est-ce qu'il a
une réelle visite en tout cas il se
trouve en face de quelqu'un qui tient un
étrange discours est cet homme pendant
toute la pièce on va se demander cet
homme qui est rentré que je vais par tom
novembre ici on va toutes les pièces
demandées si c'est dieu si c'est un
mythomane
si c'est un escroc oui parce que
marianne il ya un fou qui s'est échappée
des concierges asile dans l'immeuble
nous c'est ça enfin on en parlera après
blessure il ya plein de rebondissements
puisque nous les télés les spectateurs
on se demande si c'est vraiment alors
vous avez une idée mais c'est une pièce
qui est qui qui est policier les relais
qui donne l'impression qu'elle policière
mais en fait qui ne résout pas l'énigme
parce qu'à la fin de l'énigme il ya un
mystère qui est encore un écran que
l'énigme parce que les énigmes ont les
réseaux les mystères ont les résout pas
vous avez dit vous avez eu l'idée en
fait en vous demandant un jour est ce
que dieu souffre en regardant le 20h à
6h parce que moi j'étais en train de
voler 20 heures je trouvais pour une
fois je sens prêt parce que parfois on
entend l'oreille et puis on entendrait
juste avec un direct pour une fois je
sentais je souffrais tout ce que je
voyais je me dis dieu doit déprimer
quand il regarde le journal de 20h sur
n'importe quelle chaîne et à qui dieu
peut-il se confier quand ils dépriment
et tout d'un coup j'ai une image comme
sa fulgurante
dieu allongé sur le divan de freud et
j'ai imaginé et je me suis dit c'est de
la com ils ne sont d'accord sur rien ils
ont forcément des tas de choses à se
dire
et comme aucun ne croit en l'autre dieu
ne prend pas la psychanalyse et freud ne
croient pas en dieu
ils ont forcément une nuit assez
passionnante alors ce que j'ai ce que je
disais c'est qu'en fait bon c'est un
texte formidable c'est un très beau
texte mais c'est très théâtral quand
même si on s'ennuie pas c'est pas du
théâtre on vous raconte quelque chose
c'est pas un monologue chacun des
rebondissements et des entrées des
sorties sans arrêt un il ya des
rebondissements
au niveau du scénario effectivement
comme dans un cas comme dans un roman ce
qui fait qu'on parle de dieu enfin les
acteurs nous parle de dieudonné
l'athéisme et de la foi pendant toute la
soirée et en fait on s'ennuie pas une
seconde on regarde ça d'une façon très
agréable
alors en fait bon là je dirais le sens
de la pièce sais c'est que le xxème
siècle est le siècle de l'homme sans
dieu que je crois que le pendant des
siècles peut-être la superstition ça a
été de croire spontanément en dieu
c'était irréfléchi s'était donné comme
ça c'était culturel et je crois que au
20e siècle la nouvelle superstition
c'est denis pas croire est spontanément
on n'y croit pas et mais on est on est
athée comme avant on essaie croyants et
donc il faut toujours interrogé ses
préjugés
je trouve qu'il était intéressant que
que dans notre siècle on s'interroge sur
son incroyance et tout d'un coup j'ai
pris un athée magnifique un athée
totalement original qui est si nous la
natte et originale parce que oui et
vêtements mais parce qu'il a renouvelés
l'athéisme avec l'antique analyse en
faisant écrivant malaise dans la
civilisation et d'autres textes
il a une vision tout à fait nouvelle du
problème de dieu puisqu'il dit dieu
finalement c'est le substitut du père
terrestre défaillant donc on se crée un
père dans les nuages
j'ai comme l'invention de l'amour
l'homme se sera inventé l'amour ce sera
inventé exactement donc dieu est une
fiction de l'esprit pour répondre à des
angoisses et à des pulsions donc fruges
est un athée magnifique un athée
intelligent un athée c'est génial et
tout d'un coup fruges lui-même va être
ébranlée dans son athéisme et c'était
aussi une autre manière de poser une
question qui est aussi celle du 20è
siècle c'est bon si dieu existe comment
se sont-ils par rapport au mal oui 21 si
on peut encore croire en dieu après
auschwitz et vous vous répondait
finalement balas et auschwitz et la
faute
j'te la main les hommes parce que dieu a
créé l'homme libre il peut croire ou pas
croire et peut faire le bien ou le mal
c'est une convaincue c'est très
intéressant
c'est tout le problème du procès à
dieuze est à dire on accuse dieu du mal
que ce sont les hommes mais alors si
l'homme est libre c'est lui qui l'aurait
fait des automates
il aurait fait des automates alors
justement dans quel univers et enfin le
monde aujourd'hui est souvent racontée
comme absurde vous voulez le réenchanter
le monde voulait le rendre à nouveau
mystérieux il ya une phrase qui résume
bien tout ça dans la pièce c'est odieux
qui dit à freud jusque là tu pensais la
vie absurde vers la fin désormais tu
sauras qu'elle est peut être qu'elle est
aussi mystérieuse et c'est ça c'est un
retour un retour au ministère est ce que
le mystère et l'absurde c'est pas de
choses l'absurde c'est penser que le
monde n'a pas de sens
le mystère c'est penser que le monde a
un sens mais que ce sens mais caché oui
je crois que c'est quand même notre
position c'est à dire on est tous en
recherche de sens c'est à dire que
finalement on présuppose dans notre
recherche du sens qu'il y en avait eu de
sens et en même temps on cherche à
l'appréhender alors on la présente sous
la forme de la beauté sous la forme de
l'amour sous la forme de l'art sur la
forme de la religion on cherche toutes
les révélations du sens non parce notre
vie à courir après ça alors dire qu'il
n'y en a pas c'est une apps que vous
dites il ya plus en moi que moi
ah oui vraiment c'est à dire qu'en fait
dieu a le trésor est caché un nouveau
minimum un minimum dieu est présent en
ou sous la forme de sa question
c'est à dire que on se pose la question
de son existence et je crois que le fait
de se poser la question c'est déjà pas
la preuve de son noces et des gestes
dansés déjà ajouté le témoin pour moi
dans le doute il n'ya pas de désespoir
dans le doute au contraire et de la
lumière c'est très bien parce que vous
répondez vous avez mis des mots sur nos
interrogations sur ces des problèmes que
tout le monde se pose
sauf que vous vous êtes arrivé en parler
d'une façon simple et agréable
on a fait un débat ici à quelques temps
à partir d'un papier de pierre marc à
bruz d'angély garros vous l'avez vu et
le papier et le débat est donc voilà
alors on disait est ce qu a finalement
en france on joue des vieux os dans face
des auteurs morts où on joue des pièces
etc
ah bon vous vous êtes la preuve c'est
d'ailleurs ce que disait gilles costaz
il est quand même il ya des auteurs
comme eric emmanuel schmitt mais moi
j'ai retrouvé une phrase vous parler de
ça et vous dit effectivement dehors
c'est une chose qui était dit dans le
débat 30 ans de metteur en scène
qui ont joué les morts pour éviter la
concurrence voilà voilà où cela nous a
mené oui complètement alors je trouve
qu'il ya eu il ya eu des génies de la
mise en scène qui justifiait que
finalement on met tout le pouvoir du
théâtre et tout l'argent du théâtre dans
les mains des metteurs en scène mais
aussi des gens qui ne méritent pas
d'avoir ce pouvoir et cette argent et
finalement toute cette grande terre de
cette grande aire de la mise en scène et
de la subvention n'a pas fait bien
moindre en plus on a créé une guéguerre
entre subventionné arrivé je trouve
qu'il faut qu'on se réjouissent d'avoir
un système privé parce qu'en france non
seulement on a un théâtre d'état ou deux
régions
on est en plus 60 salles privées c'est à
dire on a encore plus de théâtre qu
ailleurs et contrairement à ce qu'on dit
partout paris est une vraie capitale de
création de théâtre et les étrangers
commencent à le savoir je peux vous dire
que il ya les étrangers une de plus en
plus vers les pièces de paris et les
emmène à l'extérieur le cas de liès mina
reza ou moi bien sûr c'est tout à fait
exemplaire de ça mais parce que à paris
il ya un public pour le théâtre à
londres à new york il n'y a que des
comédies musicales il ya très très peu
de pièces
elle joue pas longtemps l'état de son
prix 10 ans par des comédies musicales
mais que des shows nous on a du théâtre
on a des pièces on a des auteurs dans
les acteurs qui jouent des auteurs alors
il faut il faut qu'on arrête de se
mettre la tête dans le sac en disant
nous français on est nuls louey
ce pessimisme non mais c'est ce que je
vous disais si vous n'aimez pas ce pont
de l'intelligence gisait en commençant
l'émission c'est à dire que moi à
travers les boîtes rive gauche j'étais
amené à retourner au théâtre finalement
elle s'est tue c'est le bonheur de mon
année je ne cesse de cesse de le dire
alors vos projets vous aviez un projet
qui était frédéric à partir de la ville
frédéric lemaître ce que vous savez
faire j'ai également dossier ça avance
ça voilà normalement enfin partir du 20
septembre au théâtre marigny jean paul
belmondo et 24 comédiens pasqua est une
pièce sur extrêmement lourde
je romps frédéric qui est une pièce que
d'une grande histoire d'amour sur d'un
acteur avec une femme et qui se passe
dans le cadre du boulevard du crime
ouais c'est à dire le théâtre o matic
19e siècle et frédéric c'est en fait
frédéric le mail à cela le grand acteur
de cette époque alors vous a terminé là
dessus parce que finalement même un
quart d'heure ça passe vite
c'est rare comme un quart d'heure à la
télévision vous devez gagner de l'argent
certes évidemment mais vous avez une
phrase que je trouve assez joli c'est
l'argent rend pauvre c'est à dire que
finalement mais c'est assez c'est assez
beau et c'est vrai que vous
dans la critique que vous portez sur le
monde moderne vous dites qu'on ait
beaucoup dans on n'est plus dans la voir
que dans l'être et finalement vous vous
êtes là un peu comme ça le symbole de
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse beaucoup à la
spiritualité beaucoup plus à l'être qu'à
la voir mais moi d'avoir rencontré le
succès est d'avoir de l'argent ça a été
une surprise parce que le ce que
j'écrivais me semblait pas être destinée
d'emblée à avoir une telle audience et
ça ne change rien le fait que cela
arrive mais quand j'écris quelque chose
j'écris j'essaie d'écrire quelque chose
qui me plaît qui peut plaire d'abord à
mes proches et ensuite au public mais
mon premier public sont des proches et
je ne cherche pas le succès si une pièce
à un succès j'en suis trouvé d'ailleurs
pour en finir le visiteur vous pensiez
que ça n'intéresserait que vous et votre
intimité à raconter a rencontré celle du
plus grand nombre d'actes et je suis
désolé c'est malheureusement fini
j'étais très heureux de vous connaître
en tous les cas donc je rappelle le
titre de la pièce et le visiteur c'est
avec rufus avec tom novembre c'est au
théâtre marigny le réalisateur s'appelle
le metteur en scène l'appel daniel
roussée voilà si celui de montréal voilà
c'est celui que vous aviez adoré la mise
en scène à montréal aux élèves aient
décidé de le prendre
voilà donc le visiteur au théâtre
marigny merci beaucoup eric emmanuel
schmitt voilà je reçois maintenant
jacques attali pour la parution chez
fayard de son dictionnaire du 21e siècle
sous forme de mosaïque de mots un
ouvrage dans lequel l'ex conseiller du
président mitterrand et ex patron de la
berd développe avec six ans et sens de
l'anticipation
sa vision du futur jacques attali
bonsoir donc avant on va revenir très
rapidement livre avant donc vous est né
à alger en 43 vous dites souvent que
c'est un pays fantôme n'existe plus bien
entendu enfin votre algérie avoue
n'existe plus vous avez vos racines dans
la tête
récemment vous recommander pour
l'algérie l'envoi de brigades
internationales un peu comme cela a été
fait en espagne pendant la guerre civile
vous pensez sérieusement à ça je pense
qu'il faudrait le propose et continuer
le proposition c'est naturellement ça
peut pas être fait sans l'accord du
gouvernement algérien mais si le
gouvernement algérien se révèle
incapable de régler ce problème alors il
faudra bien qu'ils acceptent l'aide
communauté internationale en tant que
juifs d'algérie comme vous êtes
proclamait auprès du président chadli
vous vous feriez partie de ces brigades
internationales
faut pas pousser le ridicule jusqu'à
imaginer que je puisse remplacer des
professionnels comme ceux qui auront à
le faire mais si un à ma place de peu
jouer un rôle je le ferai avec
avec conscience et plaisir très bien
vous êtes arrivé en france dans les
enfers métropole parce qu'à l'époque
c'est la métropole dans les années dans
les années cinquante et un peu plus tôt
même que peu vos parents vous envoyez à
paris pour faire des études c'est ça
vous fait polytechnique des sorties
majeures à l'âge de 20 ans bravo si on
ce pôle et mines l'ena est ce que c'est
à cause de toutes ces grandes écoles que
claude allègre vous a demandé de
réfléchir à la réforme de l'enseignement
supérieur j'imagine que c'est une des
réseaux j'étais aussi enseignant à
l'université et dans les grandes écoles
à l'université c'est une des raisons qui
a motivé sans doute que le gouvernement
me demande de présider une commission de
réforme mais vous avez formé vraiment
que des commissions pour réformer
l'enseignement c'est pas pour dire mais
un camus quelques unes oui vous avez
raison tout mon idée c'est d'éviter que
ce soit un rapport de plus posé sur une
étagère et pour ça il faut à la fois que
la réforme soit ambitieuse et qu'on
arrive à en convaincre d'autres tel
rapport n'a de sens que s'il convainc
pas déconner françois mitterrand dans
les années 70 c'est en 81 vous avez été
nommé donc conseiller spécial où c'est
déjà dur et 191 donc dix ans auprès de
lui dans le petit bureau à côté ce qui a
dû d'ailleurs vous attire les plus
grands bureaux grand bureau vous attirer
pas mal de rancune parce que tous les
gens évidemment qu'ils étaient obligés
de passer chez vous pour aller le voir
doit vous en vouloir ensuite la berd
jusqu'en 93 donc la banque européenne de
reconstruction et de développement
voilà donc vous avez une idée il faut
bien le dire et maintenant vous dirigiez
du pense toujours une société qui
s'appelle à ea qui fait du conseil en
stratégie ans les gouvernements
voilà qui vous conseillez des
gouvernements étrangers essentiellement
des gouvernements c'est bien c'est bien
payé
vous avez publié quand même 26 essais et
romans
c'est pas mal vous êtes un peu
graphomane faut bien le dire alors venez
sens commun avec
gallo que nous avons reçus la semaine
dernière et giesbert
nous avons suivi récent en commun d'être
des surhommes quoi dire que le izik vous
vous étiez de quatre heures à 8 heures
du matin tous les jours 7 jours sur 7 et
le matin je ne sais pas écrit le soir
ouais vous dormez pas beaucoup quand
même non pas trop non mais combien parmi
4 e
ah oui ça c'est bien parce que tous les
gens qui nous regardent et disent merde
il faut pas essayer faux pas sur ses
toits destructif moi je ne le fais que
parce que je le fais naturellement vous
avez pas mauvaise mine
je cours un type plusieurs quatre heures
par les soucis lady blue avec dedans
mais vraiment on peut et vous travaillez
en plus voulait toujours dirigé la
septième de beethoven non je suis en
train d'y travailler
ah ouais c'est vrai alors j'ai c'est
très sérieux bon alors on va en arriver
au livre donc effectivement c'est comme
vous l'appelez dans un petit texte
liminaire une encyclopédie de l'avenir
un testament prénatal or c'est un
oxymoron 1 quand on dit ça oui c'est à
dire une contradiction entre deux maux
de nous qu'il a la cote et de l'autre
son contrat d'ici sont antinomiques
comme la force tranquille un peu
d'accord le dictionnaire pourquoi gbagbo
c'est facile d'accès pourquoi vous avez
choisi la forme du dictionnaire pour
faire de la cites avait peut-être
d'abord pas par impossibilité de faire
autrement
j'ai réfléchi je voulais tout dire sur
ce que j'avais en tête sur le 21e siècle
et le traité sous forme d'une thèse ou
et et est réducteur on veut pas réduire
ce qui vient à une thèse il ya trop de
choses contradictoires et le
dictionnaire permet de raconter des
choses contradictoires et en temps je
crois que c'est qu'il est ainsi qu de la
navigation du voyage de l'association
d'idées bizarre qu'un dictionnaire
permet merveilleusement de faire il ya
que c'est un mot un mot vous avez
beaucoup c'est le mot nomades nomadisme
et c'est vrai qu'à l'inter dans
lectionnaire on peut être on peut être
nomade et puis c'est effectivement une
façon de décrire le monde parte à de
petites permettent à chacun d'entre eux
où il veut de choisir s'amuse toujours
de voir quels mots les gens choisissent
d'abord ouais moi je veux dire après
alors alors c'est une ambition total
s'est même légèrement aux prétentieux
quand même alors les questions
auxquelles vous aurez pour des 1
sera-t-il possible de nourrir tous les
hommes pourra-t-on éliminer la pauvreté
y aura-t-il du travail pour tout le
monde les sciences bouleverseront tels
les modes de vie au fashion jours pour
savoir quelle guerre quelle catastrophe
écologique menaceront comment seront
gérés les contradictions entre liberté
solidarité
quand on dit ça on dit colossale quand
même un oui mais maintenant ce sont des
questions qu'il faut se poser parce
qu'on va entrer dans une période aussi
radicalement neuve sans se poser ces
questions et j'ai essayé de faire le
point sur tout ce que la science peut
dire en même temps de rêver
imaginé de créer quitte à me tromper et
sûrement et ensuite changé d'avis mais
je crois qu'il est très important
d'essayer de répondre à ces questions
oui vous dit c'est pas parce qu'on peut
pas prédire l'avenir on va essayer de
l'inventer c'est assez c'est assez joli
alors il ya un texte effectivement un
texte liminaire où vous vous parlez de
toutes les fausses prévisions qui ont
été faites au cétacé bien ça dans le
bêtisier et et ouais il ya des trucs
sans une terrible par exemple c'est le
président de 10 bm qui disait qu'on ne
vendrait pas plus de quatre ordinateurs
sur dans le monde où le président de
digital équipement qui disait que
personne n'aurait jamais un ordinateur à
domicile le club de rome ainsi qu'un lot
des rois ou qui dirait qu'on aurait pu
l'énergie l'occasion où l'un deux prix
nobel américain qui ont expliqué que
l'union soviétique serait la première
puissance de la planète avant la
saint-valentin ya c'est vrai que ça rend
ça doit rendre humble tous les
futurologues et vous dites d'ailleurs à
ce sujet là que les vrais futurologue
enfin ceux qui imaginent le mieux sont
les auteurs finale des romanciers les
romanciers surtout les romanciers
science fiction moi je suis un fou de
science fiction
je veux parler d' arthur site larrouy je
venais but eh oui
hazim offre au bercail la jules verne a
été un de ceux qui a le mieux vu au
début du chèque ce qu'allait être le
21ème siècle le xxème siècle afin d un
dvd sauf que les auteurs d'inscriptions
se trouve aussi sur deux choses
essentielles qui sont l'esthétique et
les moeurs sur lequel en général ils
sont hors taxes n va compte ils tiennent
pas compte de ça oui mais vous avez pas
me philip k.dick dans votre liste
j'aurais pu mais dalger du bic rassurez
moi non seulement subi quitterait ce qui
se passe en ce moment que le virtuel
c'est la jeune et c'est déjà ça fait
déjà
alors moi je suis allé voir un peu les
mots évidemment c'est ça donc d'abord je
suis allé vers les mots que je
connaissais pas parce que vous créez des
mots et vous créez ados l'écran on sait
que les ados l'écran ado l'écran c'est
pas une création de moi tout à fait
puisque c'est une erreur voilà ça x a
commencé à surgir aux états unis avec
screenagers c'est l'idée qu'on est à la
fois dans l'écran est rien en dehors
bien qu'on mélange la vie réelle et la
vie à virtual pas seulement l'écran de
télé mais aussi l'écran d'ordinateur et
demain la troisième dimension du virtuel
alors ça vous surprendra pas je suis
allé voir chez les noirs sexe l'âge et
pas trouvé sexe mais j'ai trouvé
sexualité alors le 25ème siècle
sexualité jacques attali ce sera d'abord
évidemment comme comme comme toujours
depuis tant de temps que ça a semé mais
aussi comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines avec la virtualité qui va
s'introduire et pour beaucoup de gens la
possibilité ou
l'impuissance à tous les sens du mot qui
consiste à avoir une sexualité que
virtuelle avec toutes les perspectives
qui s'ouvrent d'abord sur les simples
jeux vidéo du virtuel mais demain la
virtualité à trois dimensions
d'où les personnages que j'imaginais que
j'appelle clown image image absolument
qu'on pourra avoir son temps pour la
sexualité que pour le travail doit avoir
c'est soit par exemple avoir spammé
miles monroe cui devant soi qui est très
lourd avec sais pas avec qui on voudrait
note bruce willis dans pas très
longtemps fin dans moins d'un siècle
on saura faire des clones images qu'on
pourra toucher ce qui est le touchant et
évidemment la lande on transmet le son
et l'image
oui on pourra transmettre le toucher la
saveur mais le goût et l'odeur et
l'odorat donc il est à ce moment là tous
les éléments de la sexualité en tout cas
dans sa matérialité 0 seront réunies
c'est dommage qu'on est là on n'y sera
pas
je sais pas sur ce soit dommage avant
alors chez les voir drogue
c'est l'exacte n'aura pas beaucoup alors
là vous dit que effectivement c'est un
peu ce qu'on voit maintenant déjà c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui en france on
interdit le haschich la marijuana
m'enfin tout le monde prend du valium
prend du transaction comment s'appelle
n'en prend pas il ya plein de trucs
lexomil enfin bon les gens de prozac
tout ça et on va aller vers ce à quoi je
pense qu'on ira on ira aussi vers la
vers la légalisation tout parce que
parce que la prohibition a montré avec
l'alcool que ça ne fait que développer
l'économie criminelle et que et et la
drogue envoie vous a évoqué l' nos
valises qu'ils en deviennent votre
important la drogue c'est un voyage dans
beaucoup de langues d'ailleurs c'est le
même mot donc c'est un des formes de
voyage que l'humanité va permettre et je
crois qu'on va aller vers sa
légalisation mais en même temps sa
maîtrise oui alors bon il en fait ce
qu'on voit en malheureusement on peut
pas tous passer en revue mais on voit
que ce sera à peu près les mêmes
problèmes y aura des guerres il y aura
il y aura là il y aura aussi bien des
guerres que des famines la tyrannie
murale la démocratie d'après votive
s'accroître enfin en termes de
territoire est-ce qu'on va pas vers une
société à un peu benetton c'est-à-dire
métis et uniformiser s'envole
d'égalitarisme j'espère que non je crois
que la civilisation qui vient je
l'appelle civile égaux avec un double
jeu de mots d'abord le jeu de lego se
touchent chacun peut choisir des
éléments et je crois qu'on va les non
pas vers une civilisation uniforme je
crois absolument pas la domination en
anglais mais croit qu'on va vers une
civilisation où chacun pourra prendre
des éléments mais choisir sa propre sous
utilisation un peu comme on le voit dans
la musique où chaque musicien prend des
morceaux
pratique africains et du sampling quoi
voilà mais le lego c'est aussi l
apostrophe egos et intimidations
personnel égoïsme individualisé alors en
termes de carrière vous avez donc une
ascension absolument exceptionnel c'est
un des hommes les plus puissants de
france pendant pendant une dizaine
d'années après j'ai quand même eu deux
gros de gros problèmes vers bâtiment pas
raconter toute l'histoire ici mon
soi-disant votre ami elie wiesel a pas
été tendre avec vous le président
mitterrand a émis des réserves parce que
vous disiez qu'il n'avait pas cru à la
réunification allemande
vous en avez assisté signe vous perdre
partout oui c'est ça ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir aujourd'hui si je ne
change rien bon d'accord il n'ya pas cru
non non je persiste temps sur sa queue
sur le support est ce que je révise elle
bien entendu et puis l'histoire de la
berd
ils ont de la merde c'est que vous quand
vous étiez conseil d'état ou m'aviez dit
saad en bain de minuit il ya une dizaine
d'années vous gagnez 20 mille francs par
mois ce qui n'était pas énorme compte
tenu des études poussées que vous avez
fait et quand vous avez installé la berd
à londres vous avez dépensé pour
l'installer 55 millions de livres ce qui
fait quand même 550 millions de francs à
peu près ouais et ce qu'il fait pour les
gens 55 milliards de centimes maman donc
avec dieu m'a parlé mais d'abord il a
été pris d'un coup comme ça un peu comme
les 80 la folie des grandeurs là c'est
juste que le regard dans cette affaire
c'est que j'ai eu tort de ne pas me
défendre davantage un cette décision de
créer ce bâtiment n'a pas été prises par
moi mais par un comité dont je ne
faisais pas partie de cet argent était
de l'argent britannique contrôlé par les
britanniques dont pas un sou de dépenses
excessives au delà du budget a été fait
3 j'ai pris aucune décision qu'on a
ensuite reproché comme elle dumars dans
les couloirs etc
4 la moindre institutions
internationales regardez bruxelles
regarder loin regarder le fonds
monétaire est infiniment plus luxueuse
que cette institution là c'était un
mauvais procès donc vous vous en faites
vous avez vous avez regretté ce que vous
a dit je vous avais dit j'aurais dû
prendre deux semaines de vacances parce
que j'ai craqué j'étais énervé j'étais
fatigué je suis parti avant même qu'on
me mettre dehors en gros personne ne me
demandez pas voilà est en fait après
vous avez regretté
oui oui je vous étiez utile enfants
c'est à dire j'ai eu l'idée de cette
institution j'ai eu le privilège
incroyable pour moi en tout cas d'être
le solde fit la guerre d'avoir l'idée
d'une institution internationale de la
cré de trouver 10 milliards $ en trois
mois quatre mois pour à malcom x drive
là pour faire la première institution
qu'elle est de l'est et j'ai claqué la
porte et j'ai laissé mon bébé un peu
même avant qu'ils sachent marché qui va
bien pas très bien alors bon il a encore
persiste et signe
rien n'a changé bilan un peu quoi si
vous êtes né en corée mans 43 ans
maintenant je voulais être le hareng le
raymond aron de la gauche
vous l'avez pas été c'est pas vous
croyez moi je ne sais pas non je vous
pose la crise et patricia ne semble pas
de jugement non j'ai d'abord comment
vous ne vous n'oubliez pas cette
ambition
non c'est j'essaye d'avoir mis
l'ambition parce que je crois que je le
dis dans le livre qu'on n'a pas une
ville unique c'est d'avoir une des
multiples je refuse de me mettre dans
une seule catégorie mais raymond aron
était dans une seule catégorie et si je
perds jour les galets dans sa lucidité
d'inde analyse j'essaye mais je veux pas
n'être qu'une seule chose de l'or
jacques delors avait dites vous que vous
aviez l'étape d'un futur nobel de
l'économie
on verra bien d'accord donc vous donner
encore avant avant qu'on se quitte je
suis demandé juste une chose je vais
raconter une histoire un jour qui m'a
beaucoup fait rire c'est les 5 juifs
qu'on change le monde voulait pas me la
raconter chaque juif qui ont changé le
monde le premier c'est moïse qui a dit
que tout était dans la loi le second
c'est jésus qui a dit que tout est dans
l'amour le troisième c'est freud qui a
dit que tout échec ce le quatrième c'est
marx qui a dit que tout est argent est
le cinquième c'est une chaîne qui a dit
que tout était fait merci merci je vais
montrer votre livre donc voilà j'ai
montré à cette caméra
le dictionnaire du 21e siècle donc
jacques attali chez fayard merci
beaucoup très heureux de vous avoir reçu
ravi d'être venu voir et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou